b c d e f g
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum teil israels
heute gibt's ein abschluss video nämlich
der sommer abschluss wir gehen jetzt in
eine kurze sommerpause und sind im
september wieder für euch zurück und was
wäre passender als eine einschulung
torte unsere tochter ella ist schon
sechs jahre alt und kommt im september
in die schule und das video ist echt ein
bisschen schwierig für mich weil ich
weiß dass mein kleines baby einfach kein
baby mehr ist sondern jetzt vom
kindergartenkind zu einem show kind
heranwächst und wir hatten jetzt gerade
so den kindergarten abschluss und habe
im schulranzen und handgemacht und meine
erzieherin die ich schon früher in
meiner kindergartengruppe hatte hat auch
den letzten tanz mit ella gemacht es war
schon hart allein oder zwiebeln hier
oben auf dem schulhof diesen
kindergarten fest ich habe die ganze
tränenden augen katz ordnet jedenfalls
gibt es heute eine einstellungsquote für
ella denn ihr habt ja auch gerade ein
schulungs zeit und ich weiß in anderen
bundesländern ist alles immer ein
bisschen früher als in baden deswegen
gibt's heute torte und ich würde sagen
ich starte zuerst einmal damit und wird
ein bisschen dekoration herstellen aus
fondant also optisch stelle ich mir die
torte sofort ich backe eine runde torte
die relativ hoch ist also vom
durchmesser her eher schmal das ganze
wird dann mit dunklem fondant überzogen
und soll so ein bisschen mit der tafel
aussehen also muss ich dieses schwarz
oder dieses dunkelgrün einfach so ein
bisschen mit stärke abreiben darauf
kommen ganz viele bunte buchstaben unter
anderem das abc und natürlich die
buchstaben vom namen ella an die seite
der torte möchte ich ein paar teile hin
mal mit weißer farbe entweder auch ein
abc bisschen plusminus rechenaufgaben
auf die oberfläche kommen dann noch
einzelne modellierte bücher und ein
kleiner bücherwurm ich glaube dass wir
ganze ist also starten jetzt erstmal mit
den buchstaben und das innenleben da
frage ich erst nach was die torte
schmecken soll und dann bauen wir noch
das innenleben zusammen
[Musik]
dadurch dass ich jetzt hier zehn
seehofer also zellulose in dem von hand
geknetet hat werden die buchstaben auch
schon fest und die können richtig gut
aus herten und ich kann sie später
überall hinstellen und dann könnt ihr
auch wirklich so aus von dann modulierte
teile mehrere wochen aufbewahren das
immer ganz cool wenn sie komplett
durchgetrocknet sind sind sie schon fest
gehen nicht mehr kaputt mein erster
thomas ist sowieso nicht und dann kann
man immer schön alles dekorieren und
alle buchstaben die ich hinlegen werde
mache ich jetzt einfach ein bisschen
dünner dann wird es nicht nötig
für den bücherwurm nehme ich jetzt hier
ein stückchen grün dann für mich eine
lange rolle daraus dann schneide ich
sind gleichmäßige stückchen zu formen
sie dann zu einer schönen kugel und lass
dir kurz antrocknen und einen teil davon
wird der kopf und da komplett das
gesicht drauf
[Musik]
die ganze zeit ist einfach
mein kind kommt in die schule
ich war doch erst gesprochen
[Musik]
die ganze zeit waren die einschulung
orten halt immer so meister einmal für
samira das war schon schwierig
[Musik]
da alle anderen einstellung stop man
halt so für euch für eure kinder und
jetzt kommt der einstellungsstopp für
ella und das schon für mich ein bisschen
schwierig
ist bestehen
dann habe ich hier dieses süße für mich
hin und diese kugel hier vorne das wird
der kopf da machen wir jetzt noch kleine
bärchen dran die form ich aus zwei
kleine kugeln formen dann tröpfchen
unternehme ich mich hier so ein werkzeug
am besten eins mit einer spitze denn
hier oben eine kleine öffnung und hier
eine kleine
bisschen s-bahn kleber rein
[Musik]
oh
gott
[Musik]
mit einer lok hülle könnt ihr noch den
mund einprägen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier weiße modelliermasse
und die rolle ich jetzt 1 cm dick aus
und daraus kann ich dann rechtecke
schneiden und dass es dann das buch
innere
[Musik]
muscheln gleichmäßig denn bei mir in der
schule wären alle bücher gleich groß und
gleich dick schön
gleichmäßig alles recht hoch das alles
egal zack zack zack gleichmäßig ja wenn
ihr wollt dann könnt ihr hier noch die
seiten so ein bisschen einprägen er war
mit einem messer dann sieht's aus wie so
ein bisschen buchseiten dann lass dir
die jetzt kurz trocknen und könnte in
der zwischenzeit den buchumschlag machen
dafür einfach die benötigte farbe weiß
kneten fünf millimeter dick ausrollen
und dementsprechend zu schneiden hier
einfach die farbe ein bisschen größer zu
schneiden
und dann ist hier sind kleber auf
streichen und das buch zusammen pflegen
[Musik]
da könnt ihr jetzt gerne eure bücher
noch personalisieren entweder schreitet
er aus weißem von dann noch ein rechteck
zu und krebs obendrauf und könnt dann
auch zum beispiel mit lebensmittel
farbstiften was drauf schreiben oder ihr
könnt hier diese trägt die buchstaben
aufnehmen und zum beispiel in m für
mathematik und die für deutsch also da
könnt ihr einfach gerne so gestalten wie
ihr möchtet ich mache jetzt glaube ich
ein paar mit buchstaben und paar mit
etiketten
ich habe hier zum beispiel diese ganz
kleinen buchstaben
damit sticht man den vom land aus ein
bisschen glatt streichen damit die
ränder schön sauber sind
ein bisschen kleber drauf streichen und
aufs buch direkt aufdrücken
[Musik]
also bei mir früher matte blau schwarz
gelb und rot war glaube ich sage
unterricht so was baut
[Musik]
musste ein einstellungs torte
wonach soll die den schmecken
ich versteh ich nicht
ok und
[Musik]
okay das ksb mit marshmallow schokolade
vielleicht doch er
weiß ich hatte
wirklich
[Musik]
dann kann ich die jetzt trocknen lassen
und starte am besten morgen aber erst
mit meiner
trottoirs dekorationen sind angetrocknet
heute geht es darum dass ich jetzt die
böden vor backe und elle hat sicher
gewünscht eine schokoladentorte mit reis
crispy mit schokolade mit erdbeer und
natürlich erfülle ich ihr diesen wunsch
also werde ich jetzt ihre last order aus
fünf bestandteilen zu bereiten zum einen
bug ich mandl rodrik bilden die mit
schokolade verfeinert sind dann kommt
darauf eine schokoladencreme die richtig
lecker ist das ganze wird dann gefüllt
mit richtig knusprig im preis christi
darauf kommt wie von ella gewünscht die
erdbeer masse und so fühle ich quasi die
ganze torte so wird so richtig schön
saftig cremig und vor allem sehr lecker
die torte wird dann außen mit der
übrigen schokoladencreme bestrichen und
damit dann das eindecken mit fondant
einfacher wird kommt am ende noch neckar
nach strüber deswegen habe ich jetzt
hier mal ein rezept ausgepackt von den
mandl rührteig bilden diesmal mit
schokolade also cacau statt mandeln
könnt ihr auch gerne haselnüsse
verwenden ihr könnt auch kokosraspeln
nehmen ihr könnt statt butter milch auch
gerne einen kakao nehmen zum beispiel
und wirklich so dafür sorgen dass der
kuchen eben an geschmack gewinnt ich
werde das ganze in zwei backen backen
ich zeige euch noch kurz die
grundzutaten dafür braucht ihr sechs
eier eine prise salz 300 gramm zucker
vanille extrakt jeweils 300 gramm butter
milch und sonnenblumen 400 gramm mehl
plus backpulver oder verwendet man packt
mail 200 gramm gemahlene mandeln und 50
gramm
pepcom immer rum
kann man hier mein noch kindergartenkind
bald schulkind
[Musik]
also eher du hast gesagt du willst einen
schokokuchen mit reis christi
marshmallow schokolade und erdbeer
ich das für mich halt immer schon so ein
bisschen challenge den kindern dann auch
den kuchen zu backen wir ihnen schmeckt
und ich habe jetzt hier die zutaten und
back heute zwei bilden feuer
und dann lassen wir den kuchen schön
auskühlen und dann kümmere ich mich
entweder später oder morgen früh noch um
die füllung dein gesicht ist ganz
wichtig da drauf
meine ruhe stören oder
also ich gucke mir dass ich beim motiv
torten mit die aufgaben aufteilen denn
einen tag habe ich die deko zubereitet
das könnte auch zwei drei tagen vorher
machen dann backt ihr den kuchen und
lasst ihn gut abkühlen und am besten am
nächsten tag einfach füllen dekorieren
und fertig
[Musik]
ja okay ich fand es an und legt hier mit
dem teig los
haben wir spaß beim backen
[Musik]
du bist so ein experte
mach mich alle auf einmal
[Musik]
da kann dazu
haug sagt
du bist halt ein schwäbisches kind geld
immer schön sparsam aber
willst du dass der kugel nach vanille
schmeckt
ok stopp
stopp stopp
und jetzt verrühren und da muss man
jetzt aufpassen jetzt mit den haaren weg
mit dem kopf - die haare sich verfangen
deswegen immer die haare zurück und die
finger hinweg
am besten kurz von der maschine weg
gehen
[Musik]
fragen können wir was spielen
wie geht der tanz von samira
wie ging das
so
also
a
[Musik]
die gewinnseite
was
[Musik]
das ist doch ne vanillecreme
ja und später kommt cacau rein
ich meine mal gestoppt
und jetzt zehn minuten rühren
[Musik]
neun minuten
sieht gut aus aber
ich habe die sprache sagen sowohl
okay aber
er lässt mich schneller reinstetten
[Musik]
buttermilch
tavares
banker
probierst du dann probiert man jetzt
weiß
und sagt man auf mamas rezept okay ist
heute machst doch spannend
[Musik]
schmeckt
ja schmeckt sehr gut wieder nur so ok
[Musik]
danke für den emotionalen
gefühlsausbruch
danke für dein lob
geht sieht das ist die ringcon kurzem
in schwarz
ok dann habt ihr jetzt hier euren
leckeren schoko laden teig und der
kuchen wird jetzt 20 cm groß und mit der
gleichmäßig durch buck back ich in den
zwei paar kriegen das sind sehr flüssig
und deswegen solltet ihr eure back
bringe immer in backpapier einschlagen
damit nichts ausläuft
wobei es ja wirklich mit dem lochblech
mit dem bremen backblech immer eine
tolle kombis weil es praktisch eben ganz
eben ist wer man ist aber was neues
überlegt tatsächlich da wird man auch
kein backpapier mehr verwenden muss
haben wir hier so springt vom bösen und
macht und zwar sind die so haben jetzt
in drei größen und das verhindert quasi
auch das auslaufen und dann wir aus
einem bug folie dazu dies quasi auch wie
das dauert backpapier widor backt folie
wieder verwendbar und da kann man das
hier so schön rein klemm den tortenring
und dann bleibt es auch nicht aus gab
dann spart man sich so das einschlagen
jetzt verteilen wir den teig doch
drinnen und dann wird das ganze gebacken
ja komm zusammen und los
ich habe
entschuldige mich hier in pink und touch
aber nicht benutzt und was machen wir
jetzt mit denen die
nur angucken okay
du kannst ihn so lange halten ja
das passt doch abstecken
[Musik]
käsekuchen
es läuft so wie ecke zum abschied tun
wir sind dann fertig
ja das muss jetzt erstmal backen das
machen wir es heute nicht mehr weiter
geht's mit lars korte weiter und ella
maria erdbeeren ganz gerne deswegen
koche ich hier gerade erdbeeren ein
tiefe vorne mit etwas zucker und tonka
passte einfach so lange bis die
flüssigkeit verkocht ist ihr könnt das
ganze auch ein bisschen verkürzen wenn
die aga dazu gibt aber ich möchte
schauen das ist einfach so eine schöne
ersten so ein schönes etwa curie wird
denn je weniger wasser drin ist und so
mein geschmack habe ich eben auch das
kostet sie schön vor sich hin und dann
gibt es gleich mit buttercreme dann
nehme ich einfach die buttercreme zum
anrühren und habe die jetzt bereits mit
wasser angerührt und da kommt dann die
butter mit rein und weil es eine
schokoladencreme werden soll habe ich
hier noch 200 gramm zarter schokolade
und die schmerzlich jetzt einfach da
drauf das ist einfach hier die hitze aus
aber wenn ich etwas was kocht und privat
das nicht da rainha funktioniert jetzt
schmelzen
darf nur nicht zu heiß werden
[Musik]
dann sind die erdbeere gleich soweit die
schokolade ist aufgeschmolzen und ich
kann jetzt schon mal die butter ganz bei
früheren die sollte so etwa fünf bis
zehn minuten weiß cremig gerührt werden
die buttercreme muss eine halbe stunde
ziehen und ein perfekt
[Musik]
ach so ich muss die maschine hat
jetzt ist sie total richtig schön weiß
cremig und da kann ich jetzt quasi die
buttercreme hier reinhören und eben auch
die tat bitter schokolade
[Musik]
jetzt ist die buttercreme fertig und ich
werde immer noch den wunsch erfüllen sie
wollte ja so ein bischen reis christie's
dabei haben marshmallows packe ich jetzt
nicht mit rein aber ich habe mir
überlegt wie so eine art schock rossis
also ein bisschen knuspern mit in die
torte zu bringen deswegen habe ich jetzt
hier 150 gramm peter kurer türe 50 gramm
reis krieges also die schoko christie's
dann habe ich hier crisps die dunklen 50
gramm und 50 gramm mandeln
tc schon mal 100 gramm schokolade
geschmolzen einfach hier über ein
wasserbad mikrowelle geht auch 50 gramm
gebe ich jetzt zum herunterkühlen noch
dazu
zum vor kristallisieren sozusagen am
temperieren
das ist einfach nur schön einrühren
[Musik]
dann kommt jetzt die red chris und
mandeln mit rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und dann streichelt es hier einfach auf
einen bock folie zu verteilen und las
aushärten und dann hole ich jetzt schon
meine tortenböden die habe ich nämlich
im kühlschrank gelagert schön abgedeckt
damit sie durch kühl und ich so schön
durch schneiden kann
hier können da gerne noch die christ
übergeben
[Musik]
dann kann die torte jetzt gefüllt werden
ich habe die tortenböden buttercreme mit
schokolade die erdmasse und die reis
christie's perfekt und jetzt streiche
ich immer so ein bisschen buttercreme
auf den ersten boden dann kommt da mit
praktikern dann kommt da bist der
erdbeer drauf ich hätte vielleicht erst
erdbeer dann buttercreme dann weiß
christel so einfach so wie ihr wollt
egal so oder so wird sie gut
ja ich mache erst gehört das ist halt
arbeit
und das ist jetzt ein bisschen drauf
gebrütet und
[Musik]
dann finde ich so hat jetzt die gesamte
torte
[Musik]
die torte schließlich dann mit einem
tortenboden ab der schön gerade und
glatt ist weiß es euch nicht so gut
gelingt torten geradezu füllen ohne
tortenring nehmend auf jeden fall ein
tortenring dazu ich habe hier noch ein
bisschen buttercreme bricht die streiche
ich jetzt noch so an den rand und dann
werde ich eine gans herstellen aber die
dort kommt er aus meinem kühlschrank und
die garage offizier peter schokolade und
sahne gemacht und die zeige ich euch
jetzt nicht mal dazu habe ich schon
viele videos und das grundrezept gibt es
auch am kanal
das heißt die torte kommt in den
kühlschrank damit sie schön fest wird
für etwa zwei stunden und da geht es
danach weiter und jetzt ist es nicht
mehr viele zimmer fast fast so gut wie
fertig
[Musik]
sie wollten sich nicht hinter einem ice
im moment mit einem schwamm stirn
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die torte ist jetzt gut durch gekühlt
ich hab da auch einfach
eine trocken
ein tortenring traum hingesetzt und dann
da muss die folie die kann man auch
immer wieder benutzen die wasche ich
nämlich einfach
navis erst zu klein geschnitten dann
habe ich noch eine größere
sehr gut so sieht's gut aus und jetzt
werde ich die torte einmal auf die
casting box legen und was hier ganz gut
ist ich habe ja diesen neuen springt vom
boden und da ist ein bisschen kleiner
als 25 cm oder als 20 cm 20 und das ist
jetzt ganz gut weil ich dann die ganz
schön auftragen kann also da haben wir
einfach echt mal gut mitgedacht und
haben die etwas kleiner gemacht damit
jetzt die torte mit hilfe der garching
platten perfekt eingestrichen werden
kann seht ihr hier jetzt ganz gut
das sieht man jetzt hier ganz gut das
einfach so ein schöner land das heißt
oben und unten kommt jetzt ein carport
drauf und dann bekommt in dem ich gleich
eine perfekt eingestrichen eine torte
ohne zu viel arbeit das heißt da hat da
einfach bis zur zeit und
arbeitsersparnis
jetzt nehme ich hier die garage die wir
jetzt hier bei raumtemperatur gestanden
dies schön streichfähig und das gute ist
die torte ist schön kalt das heißt die
gerne schmid daran richtig schnell fest
anfangs habe ich sehr gern noch ein
bisschen flüssiger so für diese kleinen
lücken die hier sind und wenn ihr wollt
könnt ihr sie dann kurz im kühlschrank
stellen aber eben nicht so lange jetzt
erstmal eine schicht auftragen
[Musik]
wenn es dann abgezogen hört sieht so aus
dann sieht man hier unten ganz gut hier
ist noch eine lücke oder zum beispiel
hier oben oder nach vorne am rand aber
so kann ich die torte erst mal ganz kurz
kühl ist heute zu fünf bis zehn minuten
maximum man sieht ja auch schon dass die
garage richtig schön anzieht und dann
kann ich mit der restlichen danach die
ich vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen
flüssiger oder bisschen erwärme damit
sei ein flüssiger ist kann ich hier noch
mal ausgleichen abziehen und dann ist es
perfekt und das ganze eben nur in zwei
arbeitsschritten geht ganz einfach wenn
ich mir überlege ich doch früher immer
bis die torte mal gerade war das war
eigentlich immer so wird der
schwierigste part dass die einfach schön
gerade ist eine schöne ecken hat und
jetzt geht das alles ein bisschen
schneller
jetzt nehme ich das obere garching bord
ab einfach mit einer palette vorsichtig
ablösen
und dann die oberfläche auch glatt
streichen
da brauche ich auch mal ein bisschen so
als untergrund für den content
[Musik]
also ich seh thema erst schön den rand
dann die oberfläche und wenn die
oberfläche gemacht ist einmal am rand
entlang und den rest sieht er mit einer
palette einfach zur mitte hin und dann
ist die torte perfekt gemacht
wenn ihr noch ein paar probleme hat von
torte glattstreichen einstreichen dass
sie gerade wird dann schreibt mir
einfach gerne in die kommentare dann
mache ich gern noch mal so ein basic
video dazu wo wirklich so schritt für
schritt erklären
dann kann die hier zitierten noch mal
kurz in den kühlschrank stellen mein von
dann schon vorbereiten und schön weich
gelegen und damit das ganze in der tafel
optik wird nämlich einfach etwas grün
und schwarz damit ich ein schönes
dunkelgrün hat
[Musik]
somit ist jetzt alle wisst ich hasse
fondant kneten
hast dich einfach ich will seit zehn
jahren eine fondant knetmaschine
das tut mir in den fingern w und du
wirst du gestrengen
richtig wütend dass von danwitz etwas
erfunden aber
meine finger wir machen
vor allem wenn man farben mischt dann
sieht man ja was nicht vergessen hat
habe ich starke männer und frauen in
meinem team
die mir jetzt fondant kneten
[Musik]
falls ihr auch ein praktikum sie war und
ich ja
das ist eine richtig schöne tafel farbe
würde ich sagen und jetzt wird der
fondant auf becker strecke ausgerollt
das ist eine stärke aus kartoffeln und
das ist eine reine kartoffelstärke ist
schön pulvrig wie man sieht und die
klebt dann später nicht am fondant und
das ist richtig gut mit einfach schön
gleichmäßig ausrollen
[Musik]
die torte gern mit wissen was drin spray
einströmen damit er von sand haften
bleibt und die von dann decke drüber
ausrollen
[Musik]
und dann nimmt ihr hier immer einen
strang in die hand also so wie sein die
vom land decke die eine hand sieht den
von dort weg und die andere streicht von
oben nach unten platz
[Musik]
was so ein bisschen sonne geduld arbeit
aber auch wenn es so aussieht als würde
dieser von dann niemals glatt werden
einfach geduldig weiter arbeiten von
oben nach unten gleiten dann wird das
schön glatt jetzt schneide ich hier kurz
großzügig erstmal den rand weg mich
nervt karten bis sind das hier oben so
eine kleine welle ist weil ich denn
fondant zu lange habt aufgerollt liegen
lassen ich mag es eigentlich nach denen
sie aufzuholen aber
klingt anders
den kann ich einfach zusammen kneten
luftdicht verpacken und wieder nächstes
nur weiter benutzen
und jetzt mache ich gern mal kurz upside
down denn die garching platte und 100
die muss noch weg
[Musik]
dieses rutschig
jetzt auch noch
mag ich ja
12 trägt
geschafft
[Musik]
und wenn die torte sowieso schon
umgedreht ist aber perfekt weil man sie
dann auch schön glätten kann so dass die
ränder wirklich gerade werden also
einfach mit zwei torten klettern
und hier unten könnt ihr dann immer
diese diesen übergang richtig schön
gerade
ein bisschen
hatte so richtig schöne kannte
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich meine tortenplatte auch
da werde ich später die torte nämlich
servieren finde ich einfach immer schön
[Musik]
das war der punkt an dem ich entspanne
weil ich weiß meine torte ist mit
fondant überzogen und es sieht auch die
so schlecht aus da oben die kleine macke
die nervt mich aber da kommt jetzt
gleich dicke drauf
und jetzt kann ich die torte in den
kühlschrank stellen ich stelle von
antworten im kühlschrank das werde ich
immer gefragt allerdings denke ich sie
nicht mehr ab also da kommt jetzt keine
trockenhaube immer drauf weil ansonsten
der fondant nämlich schwitzen würde und
jetzt kommt den kühlschrank ich kann
hier aufräumen kurzen mittagspause mit
ella machen und dann wird die torte
gleich fertig dekoriert
naja ist da etwa mensch schulkind
ja mathe deutsch und kann man hier noch
andere fächer draufschreiben und die
tafel können wir auch gleich zusammen
beschriften
das überlegen wir uns jetzt noch
möchtest du kurz den kühlschrank öffnen
den rechten
wie jetzt die torte fertig dekoriert ich
hab ich hier weiter lebensmittelfarbe zu
pulver farbe die könnt ihr mit wasser
oder zum beispiel mit einem alkohol an
menschen und jetzt werde ich hier so ein
paar linien drauf zeichnen und macht es
klappt einfach mit so einer karte habe
ich mir überlegt vielleicht klappt's
vielleicht
doch nicht wenn man rechts nehmen und
soll eine tafel sein
u
[Musik]
klappt
das ist meine lieben ist die
erstklässler miniatur
da machen jetzt gleich eine lateinische
ausgangsschrift handy das
okay und dann machen wir noch ein plus -
rechnung und noch eine grafische
zeichnung ja dann schreibe ich jetzt
mein erster schultag
[Musik]
ja das ist doch mal eine schöne tasse
jedenfalls werde ich jetzt hier noch die
elemente aus fondant ein bisschen mit
clubs ab pulver mit lebensmittelfarbe
einfach bewundern damit das ganze schön
ist oder sie toll aus das quält der lhc
ist mein nachname mitnehmen das ist
schön
[Musik]
damit jetzt die torte schön
zusammengesetzt
also ich find tatsächlich so vom aufwand
her links somit den büchern
all dies so edel
[Musik]
zum glück heißt irgendwie
ihrem guard mathilde
hannelore maria und hat zu fünf name
hintereinander also erst noch auf die
torte wenn ihr halt längere namen habt
dann
herr prof
wie wäre es so der pilot der ja
da kommt dass da hoch und hier könnt
vielleicht noch ein zweites leben
[Musik]
sind die ganzen buchstaben die so runter
fallen und die l das sind die buchstaben
dieser ist offen hervorstechen und
die liegen hier so am rand gleich ich
muss nun überlegen wo meine raupe der
bücher wo
rauskommt
vielleicht hier vorne
und dann schlängelt sich durch die toto
so durch
[Musik]
so sieht die dort jetzt aus ich bin auch
richtig glücklich darüber und hier ist
noch das buch wasella modelliert hat hat
sie richtig schön gemacht und jetzt
würde ich sagen wir unser schulkind
hierher ella du darfst bakom
was dem keller
okay
das kind trinkt sie so
lecker einer hat es denn der
einstellungs torte wie gefällt dir ja
ich habe hier noch eine aufgabe für dich
also zum einen muss ich sagen meine war
nicht trocken und ich musste ein
bisschen retten das gut alles gerettet
und dann habe ich noch aufgaben für dich
hier und zwar weiß was hier steht
das lernen in der schule steht mein
erster schultag
und weiß was hier steht
a
b c d e f g h i und weiter geht s bei
mir gar nicht und hier was geht hier
matheaufgaben
[Musik]
was was es vier was überstehen am
karlsplatz 3 ist
willst du sie nur an also soll ich
mich
stellen niemals dazu hin dass dahin
schreiben
ich habe einfach so einfache aufgaben
gemacht
ja warum also eine 4 schreibst du so so
so und so
das nämlich so krass die ella kann schon
im kopfrechnen
sehr gut mit pinsel zu schreiben es ein
bisschen schwierig da muss man immer den
pinsel war das zeige ich euch auch mal
nicht wie ein stift sondern den pinsel
halt auch halt nur dann macht man so
leichtere bewegung ist so trotzdem es
ist schwierig selbst für mich wo wir
doch mal
meine küche hätte schon rechnen kann
sehr gut
ja und jetzt was macht man mit so einer
torte und
dann
willst du sehen wie sie innen aussieht
anschneiden
[Musik]
aber dies zum essen da und die sachen
können wir aufheben obendrauf okay zumal
zusammenschneiden
man mit den unteren arm weg
heißt es knuspern gehört das sind die
reis crosbys
jetzt holen wir hier eine gabel
daumen drücken das ist gut aussieht
oh das tortenstück oh mein gott ist da
fällt
das erste ist halt immer schwierig auch
sowas sagen
[Musik]
auf einer skala von 1 bis 10 1 ist ganz
schlecht und 10 ist ganz gut wie
schmeckt die torte oder warte in
schulnoten 1 1 ist eine sehr gut und mir
sex ist ganz schlecht welche note gibst
du meine torte unserer torte
einsplus
danke kriege ich dann zeugnis von dir
kulisse perfekt also er bewertet unsere
torte mit einer eins plus da bin ich
richtig happy und wenn ihr wollt könnt
ihr euch auch gern noch die
einschulungsrate von samira anschauen
die ist natürlich fünf jahre her war
noch in unserer alten wohnung daniela
auch schon da aber noch ganz klein ja
gut dann würde ich sagen genießen wir
die torte jetzt hier alle gemeinsam im
team und mit der familie ich wünsche mir
ganz viel spaß und du kannst vielleicht
oder dessen eintagsfliege ist nicht
schlimm und du kannst vielleicht noch
ganz kurz erzählen
worauf du dich in der schule am meisten
freue ist
worauf freust du dich am meisten
sport mathe kunst im sport und
vielleicht auf die schöne zeit mit
deinen freunden
und mit einem lernen
und dass du ganz viel ernst
ich könnte den tag mit jetzt ewig
weiterführen
jetzt haben wir den moment für die
ewigkeit eingefangen
so hat jetzt von den zuschauern
verabschieden
also el alam ist auch us dollar ist an
euch wir gehen jetzt in die sommerpause
das bedeutet hier gibt es jetzt im
august erstmal keine videos von mir
zumindest keine großen mittwochs und
sonntags videos meine rezepte könnt ihr
hier nachlesen in der app oder auch
sallys - blog.de und wir sind dann
wieder zurück mit dem ersten sonntags
video am vierten september
da gibt es wohl möglich eine torte und
falls ihr uns in berlin besuchen wollt
wir sind nämlich auf der ifa auf der
internationalen funkausstellung beim
stand von bosch da sind wir am dritten
september das heißt samstag am dritten
september könnt ihr uns dort live
treffen mein team ist mit dabei woran es
mit dabei wir werden dort in der küche
kochen und backen ich bin den ganzen tag
für euch da signierstunde fotos bücher
werden signiert wir sind da wir können
uns unterhalten wir können uns
kennenlernen und es ist quasi auch so
das erste event was er wieder wahrnehmen
werden freuen uns darauf am samstag in
berlin und am sonntag wieder ganz wie
gewöhnlich auf meinen youtube kanal ihre
bikinis der zitate ich wünsche euch
einen wunderschönen sommer und wir sehen
uns wieder
[Musik]